tell us your story from where you were
at to becoming an fbi agent my brother
peter gave me a call and said look now
that you're a prosecutor we should do
something about the director of the camp
when we were kids i went undercover i
met with the guy i wore a wire and we
locked up the guy correcting that
injustice ended up with the agent
pushing over an application to me and
saying you should join the fbi becoming
a murderer committing major crimes of
taking someone's life is it nurture is
it nature the way i like to summarize it
is genetics loads the gun personality
and psychology aims it and your
experiences pull the trigger what do you
mean when you say snipers have a god
complex it's not as easy to pull the
trigger on human beings as it is on
paper targets generally people choose to
snipe versus one-on-one contact with
their victims because they want to feel
omnipotent they want to feel powerful
[Music]
my guest today had a 22-year career with
the fbi and here's what's so interesting
about him i've interviewed a lot of fbi
guys and i've watched a lot of
commentary and interviews from fbi
agents he was a supervisor and this is
probably one of the best teachers in the
area of crime that i've seen myself
on how they go about catching a bad guy
what is the idea of a sniper why this
sniper has a god complex and is it
nurture versus nature the fact that
somebody becomes a killer the way he
breaks it down is very interesting and
he's from an interesting family as well
both he and his brother two brothers our
fbi agents him and his other brother tim
are fbi agents peter took a different
route became a business owner now
they're all running the business
together which we'll talk about maybe
throughout the interview but i haven't
said that jim thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
[Music]
again we were talking offline before we
started doing the interview i was
fascinated about your uh style of
teaching but before we get into it uh on
some of the questions i got i'd like to
profile somebody today as well hopefully
we'll be able to do that because i was
watching your system on how you you know
the the catch a liar the different signs
obviously you said there's nothing
that's undisputable there's not an
undisputable way of catching a lie but
there's a system for it but
you know you don't become an fbi agent
because uh you just wake up when they
become an fbi agent at least i don't
think maybe that was the case with you
typically there's got to be a reason to
drive a story family upbringing in
sports you know correcting an injustice
tell us your story from where you were
at to becoming an fbi agent well that's
pretty pretty insightful on your part
there because there are at least two
injustices that i think i tried to
correct
um and becoming an fbi agent helped me
do that
uh but when i was a kid
just a toddler i was always exploring
things i remember i asked my mother how
the clock in the kitchen works and she
said well you plug it in and electricity
makes it move and i was like no i mean
how do the hands know how fast to go so
i couldn't reach the one in the kitchen
but i could stand on a chair and grab
the cuckoo clock in the living room and
i got a pair of pliers and a screwdriver
and i and i opened up the back of it i
took out all the gears and figured out
why
the one arm went faster than the other
and of course my mother found me with
the whole thing all disassembled on the
living room floor and
she let out a scream because it was a
family heirloom and i carefully put it
all back together and to me that kind of
sense of exploration it wan i wanted to
be a detective i wanted to figure things
out but then
i became a chemistry major in college
chemistry and philosophy then went to
law school and i thought well joining
the police department would kind of be
taking a step backwards i couldn't just
walk in to become a detective
and so i became a prosecutor and that
was very fulfilling very busy work but
then
i
i kind of had this thing in the back of
my head my grandfather
was
killed
by the mob he owned a construction
company in in new york city he wasn't
playing their games and he ended up
getting accidentally electrocuted on
this on the site and a month later his
son who took over the company my my
cousin excuse me my uncle guy
he was also killed in an accidental
bulldozer accident
and my father actually went to law
school on the gi bill
to sue to get the company back and
by the time he did these uh sort of mob
union guys had taken over sold off all
the assets and he got you know pennies
for this company that was actually doing
millions of dollars of work they they
built the manhattan county courthouse a
bunch of buildings on fordham columbia
columbia law school
and uh the brooklyn battery tunnel you
know they were doing major jobs and and
it was gone so my father had to start
from scratch so i think that that
sense of injustice ingrained in myself
and my brother tim i
desire to
actually make sure justice happens for
other people
and the other thing was that my brother
peter gave me a call and said look now
that you're a prosecutor
we should do something about
that the director of the camp when we
were kids
and i said whoa why and he said because
i once
snuck into his office and i found
hundreds of pictures of him molesting
boys
and i said i thought i was the only one
and so the next day i went to the fbi
nypd task force on sexual exploitation
of children
we started a case and i went undercover
i met with the guy i
wore a wire and
we we locked up the guy and he had been
responsible for
somewhere between 50 and 200 victims
over the course of his career he was he
worked for the catholic church
he taught in 23
excuse me he taught in 13 different
catholic schools over 23 years every
time there was an allegation they let
him walk out the door and go down the
street to another school
and so
correcting that injustice ended up with
the agent pushing over an application to
me at the end of the trial and saying
you should join the fbi you did an
amazing job on this case and literally
that's how i became an fbi agent so it
was a sense of correcting injustice and
it helped me turn something that was
very difficult in my life into something
very positive by helping victims get
through the same kind of thing or very
different things
it made me feel better about the
experience i had in my life so you said
peter called not tim right so peter's
the one that's not the fbi agent that
called to you when you were a prosecutor
saying let's go after that director did
he know the story with you and the
director or he did not not until he made
that call i never told anyone okay well
i did tell the priest at my school who
told me
i absolve you of your sins say nothing
more about this
years later i would be investigating
that same priest who molested kids in my
class you got to be kidding me no i'm
serious and
so you know there was a lot of stuff
that happened that uh i felt really set
me on a course to try to correct things
rather than
let them
exist as they were now jim you're from
uh san mateo california but you're from
new york yes yeah which clementi what
kind of uh what nationality is your
family mom and dad
uh well mom was actually scotch irish
and my father was italian so i'm about
when i did 23 and me it's like basically
49.2
italian 49.4 percent irish
so
i'm about
half and half there so they told you the
truth you see when i did mine on
ancestry
uh i i was told i'm half a syrian half
armenian but i'm 18 italian and i still
can't figure out who hooked up with an
italian so that's a mystery in our
family mom and dad won't tell me
anything so it could have been yeah it
could have been something
way way way back in history it probably
was i mean listen i wouldn't be
surprised because italians are pretty
smooth
and uh somebody was probably a smooth
talker but but are you still a catholic
are you still a catholic yourself or no
i actually separated from the church i i
was pretty disgusted by how they handled
things not i mean i'm only giving you
this scratching of the circles but i did
when i joined the fbi they assigned me
to the very task force the sexual
exploitation of children task force in
new york city it was an nypd fbi joint
task force i worked that task force for
several years and
while i was there
unfortunately i came into contact with a
number of
other situations in which the catholic
church had literally chosen to
crush things under the rug rather than
address the victimization of children
and i couldn't stand for that yeah i
just wonder because when a story like
that happens dramatically you can't uh
you know it's it's pretty tough to
go back to no matter how much people try
to explain it to you like listen this is
a life changing anyways okay sounds good
well thank you for sharing that uh with
myself in the audience so now that we
know that let's get right into your
world of being an fbi agent so
if you don't mind taking a minute you
know the part the way you explain it i
asked this question who was i
interviewing the the crime uh detective
from uk
uh uh
paul milleri yeah palmillary yeah from
uk who his job was to go interview these
guys and find out what it is and i asked
him the question
about nature versus nurture because you
know sometimes you're in school we had
this one kid who was six years old who
liked to throw dogs out the window from
fourth floor and like
you gotta have something off to do that
at six years old and he was always a
little weird right when he would do
certain things so explain the nurture
versus nature of somebody who is born
who eventually ends up becoming a
murderer committing major crimes of
taking someone's life is it nurture is
it nature
well um i think people are are skipping
a very important component when you talk
about nature versus nurture it's
actually a combination of bio psycho and
social so
you have a certain propensity or
potentiality with your genetics you're
born with the abilities to do certain
things and the inabilities to do other
things
but your psychology and your personality
are the filter through which you
experience life
so your socialization is actually
filtered through your psychology and
personality
and then your
personality is actually made
through
the millions of little private decisions
you make in your own brain so that's how
you affect
how life affects you
and so the way i like to summarize it is
genetics loads the gun
personality and psychology aims it
and your experiences pull the trigger so
unless you have that
perfect storm of all three aspects
you won't get somebody who's gonna go
out and kill
somebody you know they've done twin
studies where where one twin who's got
the same genetics identical twins is in
a is it in a difficult situation and
his parents are suffering and they're
sacrificing and they're not even getting
enough food right because they're
feeding their kids and that one kid says
i i love my parents i i i see how they
suffer for me when i grow up i want to
make sure they want for nothing i want
to take care of them and the other twin
says are you kidding me
they don't even give us what we deserve
we deserve better they're failures i
hate them
and
that's the same genetics but the
decisions that the one twin made in his
own mind instead of pushing away from
the dark side he embraces it and that's
the negative spin he puts on everything
he experiences and i think that's why
you get people who ultimately go down
the road of being a killer or a serial
killer or a rapist or zero rapist
because they made these tiny little
decisions in their brains that they're
more important than other people
so so okay so i like the way you put it
you said uh
genetics loads the gun personality and
psychology aims it but then your
experience pulls the trigger right so
okay so now let's we just had the uh
kyle rittenhouse uh case by the way 10
minutes before we did the interview i'm
sure you saw that being in the world not
guilty not guilty not guilty
so what is it in his case okay so that's
a current event that right now everybody
around the world is talking about
absolutely what how would you classify
his case
well to me
some of the the circumstances that came
out in the trial that people didn't know
beforehand the fact
is that he did not purchase that weapon
he had a friend purchased it but he
couldn't wait to get his hands on it
he wanted to feel more powerful he felt
helpless and he wanted something that
was going to give him that power and
then
the the the riots and the uprising and
the protests gave him the opportunity to
be called upon to be powerful with this
weapon and so this is why we don't give
guns to 17 year olds this is why we have
rules you can't buy it until you're 18.
now if it's supervised with an adult you
can operate one earlier if you know how
to do it and you can do it safely but he
did not have those circumstances but in
this case because of the way the trial
fell out because of the way the evidence
was or wasn't turned over some of these
things were not given to the jury and
and the charges of him illegally
possessing a weapon were dropped by the
judge they were they were thrown out
and that sort of undermined the entire
case but if you look at it behaviorally
this is a young man now who was a boy at
the time a teenager who
felt powerless
and that weapon in his hand gave him
power
so what did he do he went out to
basically exercised that power in a
situation where he felt justified to do
it so in his brain he said and and there
was actually
quotes of him saying watching protests
earlier on and violence earlier on
saying oh man i wish i had my gun right
this is something that he had thought
about a long time
but he put himself in that opportunity
so that he could use that gun and no
matter what somebody else did
i believe
that this is something that he
was destined to do he wanted to do this
his personality drove him to be in a
position where he could pull that
trigger
and that was an irresponsible thing at
the very least for him to do
i believe that
that he went out there
because he wanted to actually exercise
that power and unfortunately ended in
the death of two people a serious injury
to a third
i don't know
all the facts and circumstances because
obviously i wasn't there so i don't know
if this jury's verdict was was proper or
not
but i do know there are going to be
people that are very displeased with it
thinking that it was literally just
because of biases unfortunately i think
what it was was because of the legal way
the the legalities and the laws and how
they are enforced in that particular
state i don't believe that the jury got
it wrong i think that unfortunately the
case
fell apart because of when and how the
evidence was presented yeah it's by the
way when you said he was destined do you
think in his mind he was doing the right
thing and he was being a hero
or do you think it is more and again
everything you say it's it's nothing is
undisputable the word you say everything
is possibly right but do you think in
his mind is like look
i'm sick and tired of seeing all these
protesting and what they're doing to the
business i'm going to go be a hero and
i'm going to be the next you know
william wallace i'm going to be a
protector i'm going to be you know this
guy from this movie absolutely okay so
you think he's coming from the evil
standpoint
and the only question that remains is
what was in his heart what was in his
mind in terms of bias is it something
that he gets all fired up about this
because he is a biased person or is it
not i mean many people thought that the
people that he killed and shot were
actually african-americans but they
weren't they were not white people yeah
right they were white people who were
advocating for black lives matter and
and unfortunately
got involved in in violence i do not
believe at all that violence was
something that had to happen on either
side of that
it's an unfortunate choice that people
made and unfortunately when you have mob
violence people do a lot worse than they
do on their own than they would ever do
on their own and that's part of people's
personalities and going along and this
is all behavior that we've documented
throughout history
you know to me this this this obviously
we can take at different angles one guy
brought up the politics side i said
listen if this guy's uh if you're
thinking this is political the judge
that said not guilty not guilty not
guilty based on what the jury said the
judge was appointed by obama so it can't
be political this is a you know of
course they want to make it political
don't get me wrong the state is worried
500 national guards you've read it i've
read it we know the stories about how
worried they are about what could
potentially happen there but all i think
about in a situation like this is how we
can improve as a society not how to work
backwards so you know as a parent your
parents would say you know nothing good
happens after midnight you know those
stories like mom you don't know what
you're talking i'm going to an after
hour so four o'clock in the morning you
know and then one instance you go to a
club and there's shooting you know guy
gets shot one of your friends gets shot
like you know what man half these things
parents tell you when you're a kid about
not going to these places is right so
you know even getting yourself caught up
to go get in a protesting like that a
riot
to support something that turns ugly
you're one foolish decision away from
ruin your life so i i couldn't agree
with you more and unfortunately as i
said
it's it's the kind of thing where it's
sort of a snowball effect i mean once he
went out there with the intent to to
sort of assert this new power that he
had with this gun uh this kind of thing
was inevitable i think for him yeah i
you know i wonder how much of that has
to do with the steering of the path
whether what was going on with the
politics at the time the left the right
the media who knows but all i know is it
led to two people not being here right
now so whether it's guilty or not guilty
that family is still going to be
mourning about the loss of to their kids
brother you know whoever that you know
the the connection it is to the family
but okay so let's process that from a
logical standpoint is there any way
based on these three things we're
talking about genetics loads the gun
great mass is pretty cool i got a gun
i'm powerful right you know personality
and psychology aims all right and then
you got the experience that's like i'm
going to pull the trigger
you know like the the what's that one
movie where you prevent a crime from
happening before it happens with tom
cruise what was the name of that movie
it's not born night then it's not the
uh uh uh anyways there was a movie that
he did something in fact right
i get the movie here when you when you
when i ask a question from you
what technology
or data predictive analytics is the fbi
currently working on
to be able to
get to the point of
one of these things not triggering the
last one if that makes any sense yeah
it's funny you mentioned that uh so
when i when i was in the behavioral
analysis unit which is part of the
national center for the analysis of
violent crime we were doing a number of
different research projects
um everything from
parents who kill their kids to people
who attack the elderly uh to
serial killers and sex offenders all of
those studies were going on
simultaneously
the whole purpose of that is to look at
behavior to try to find points of
intervention in the written house case
the point of intervention is
would have been preventing him from
getting that weapon until he was
developmentally
mature enough to actually
hold it and use it and not like a child
would unfortunately
because he was young i think this is why
i mean there were lots of other people
out there with the same kind of weapons
who didn't kill anybody that night
right so what was the difference i think
it was his develop developmental
immaturity and that could have been
stopped i don't know by parents or some
other adult that
was in that uh sort of circle of
influence around him someone who heard
him say uh i can't i wish i had my gun
and and intervened at that point and
said wait a minute that's not the answer
here that's only going to escalate the
violence we need to de-escalate the
violence and it's like when i went to
guantanamo
and and i was i was tasked with
evaluating their interrogation program
and i discovered that they were
torturing people
and
put a stop to it it i i was horrified
one because they're they're
literally
hurting defenseless people i don't care
what they did in the past they are now
shackled they are in u.s custody and
they're being tortured that is not right
from a human standpoint but it's also
wrong from a standpoint of getting
accurate and reliable information so i
taught them how to do rapport-based
interrogation and i think rapport-based
intervention in the kyle rittenhouse
case could have prevented him from being
out there that night with his weapon
with the weapon that was not legally
purchased for him that he was not
allowed to possess
yet because he wasn't yet 18
and i think that rapport rapport-based
intervention could have helped him avoid
that situation so i want to get into
that but before getting into that by the
way the movie was called minority report
that's what the movie was and i watched
the movie in regards to uh guantanamo
bay which they did a great job by the
way the
more mauritanian i don't know how to
pronounce the ward i don't know if you
saw the movie or not it's uh ortanian
yes
i'm not sure i saw the report i i saw
that one yeah this one here i think
you've got to watch this one as well
because it's based on the true story
of mohamed
salahi who was held there for 14 years
and tortured and it's a very painful
movie to watch but they do a great job
depicting what happened uh
i'm not allowed to talk about the
particular
people that were involved but i i'm
pretty certain i know
what happened behind the scenes in that
movie yeah i'm sure you do that's why i
brought it up so uh so going back to
what you said so report based
intervention rapport
sorry report like building rapport you
know tell me about yourself tell me
about upbringing so walk me through
the torture base is torture based pretty
much what we think it is
uh where you know pain anything they can
to eventually get this person to say yes
and then is rapport based taking a
little bit more time to build a
relationship can you give us the
differentiation from your point of view
both sides of it so
the
the program that they were
implementing it was called
fear up person down
all right so they wanted to scare these
people
and
and remove them their humanity from them
basically they were humiliating them
they were confusing them they were
keeping them up all night they were
shining bright lights in their face they
were playing loud music they were having
guard dogs they were doing all sorts
of very cruel things and then it just
escalated as time went on to worse and
worse things and
and what that does
especially with people who have lived a
tough and hardened life
is reinforce
that the people who are doing this to
you
are the same ones who made your life and
your family's life and your
grandfather's life miserable so
it hardens them
in their own goals
it does not
undermine their expectations like
rapport based interrogation does
what happens is they come
they come to this situation and they
expect to be treated horribly by the
monsters that have created this
in their mind because this is how they
were trained this is how they were
recruited
these monsters from america
they
caused all this
pain and suffering in your life and your
family's life so
the torture only reinforces that but if
you give them dignity and respect and
share a human
connection that bridge that you build
with them by sharing something with your
from yourself
and asking and
being sincere about inquiring about
their lives and their faith and their
culture
by doing that
it shows them that you're a human being
just like they are and that connection
is a is a hell of a lot stronger than
anything you'll ever build by hurting
someone
so
what it is is it undermines their
expectations
they now don't understand wait a minute
uh i thought all these people were evil
and monsters why is this person being
nice to me
and then they start
saying well maybe maybe what i found out
before wasn't true what i found out now
is true
and you have an opportunity there to
actually build a connection and get
people to cooperate
rather than
to
burn their resolve to kill you to
destroy your society to destroy your
faith
so
i what i did was i asked them
to give me
their
worst detainee the one that was
hardened the most and that would not at
all
cooperate
and he was actually a hafiz so he he
memorized the quran and any time anybody
tried to interrogate him he would just
quietly whisper the quran to himself and
he was in another world he never even
acknowledged another person
and in the over the course of 11 days
i met with him i gave him dignity and
respect i treated him like a human being
i gave him control over when and how we
met and
i i told him i'm here i'm a behavioral
analyst i'm stuck here for months i
would love to take the opportunity to
to learn about your faith and your
culture and you as a person
and slowly i revealed things about
myself and
eventually he revealed things about
himself and at the end he said jim my
friend what can i do for you
and he began to cooperate with us fully
and that was to demonstrate how the
process works it takes a little more
time maybe
but it actually is effective at getting
accurate and reliable information
and it doesn't
perpetuate the the
horror stories that they've learned
growing up about us
it actually helps them understand us
jim how much of this is are you a sports
guy or no
uh somewhat but you know i i like
playing it playing sports rather than
just watching it on tv are you a giants
fan are you a jets fan are you a knicks
fan are you yankees fans the only team
ever is the yankees i'm sorry all right
so far i mean you sound like you'd be a
yankees guy forget about it yeah so so
go with the yankees you know so you know
how some in baseball
uh there's different philosophies to win
a world series the braves for the
longest time in the 90s they had a
strong pitching uh philosophy right and
they had these all these kevin millwood
uh john smalls glavin uh i'm forgetting
the main guy greg maddox they had all
these guys right
and they won one but they were always
the best team in the league right you go
to
the yankees the way they do they wait
for guys to go to other teams and they
come and overpay them and bring them to
the yankees and dominate the marketplace
right you look at the tampa bay devil
raise recently where it's the pitchers
pitched three innings instead of five or
complete games you don't have a lot of
complete games how much of this is
fear up person down versus rapport
based interven intervention how much of
it is philosophy versus results meaning
this is how we get our results this is
how you do it versus no
report based is more effective than fear
up person down because i had friends who
were in in delta and i had friends who
were
dealt with those guys directly so to
them
you know they've seen how they were what
would you say to somebody that says it's
easy for him to say
we deal with these guys they're not as
nice as jim makes it out to be what
would you say to those folks
well i would say there there are
different sets of
exigencies in different circumstances if
you're in a battlefield
and
somebody has information about
500 people who are about to be killed
there are ways that
military people deal with those people
that is not an in-custody interrogation
situation here's the thing in the fbi we
have always
used constitutionally approved grounds
for interrogation
it's a different it's a more difficult
route to take
but
it has proven over a hundred years
that we can actually get people who are
just as bad as any terrorists serial
killers people who have taken the lives
of of elderly people people innocent
people in their own home children
they have viciously
killed them but we've gotten them to
cooperate and actually admit what they
did wrong and how did we do that again
by building a bridge
a human bridge because no matter how
hard that terrorist is or that battle
combatant is there's still a human being
and if you can get to that humanity and
make a connection
then the chances of you getting reliable
and accurate information are much
greater and that's
that's the the strictures under which
all fbi agents and law enforcement
officers operate
military people are in a different world
and i don't know that world as well i
don't know if it actually
produces on in the moment
accurate and reliable information but i
know that it's illegal for anybody to do
that to somebody when they're in custody
and i know that
the
the torture statute in the united states
is very clear about it well you know the
geneva convention
their their uh the code amongst how
you're supposed to treat a pow is a
pretty clear code amongst everybody that
follows yes but but you and i know what
happens the
the part that made it interesting with
paul mallory the guy from uk who his job
is to go sit down and talk to these guys
that just apparently killed somebody and
they're potentially the suspect is he
says in uk the laws i have 36 hours
so i have to try to get information on
36 hours in your world you have time on
your side so maybe you're like look i'm
gonna be here for six months i don't
really have any other place to go tell
me a little bit more about the quran
what up i can see that because you're
getting me
to sit down and say you know what [ __ ]
this ah
i like this guy man listen here's really
what happened you know that that that
right but uh when i when i gave you that
example i mean that this is a this is a
a person who was in
custody for quite a bit of time who had
been treated badly already and so i had
to sort of undo all the damage that was
done but when we're talking about a law
enforcement interrogation even of serial
killers
generally we say you know
spend at least four hours with the
person but i'm talking about when we're
when you're in that situation generally
it happens within four to six to eight
hours it's not something that takes days
it's literally
the ability of someone to be
you know human to another person and to
show that there is
a way to help you through the situation
and it has to be based on that person's
personality so what we want to do is
assess that and certain people who are
very narcissistic you have to feed their
ego certain people who are very sort of
they're vulnerable narcissists in other
words they puff out their chest because
they feel so badly about themselves
so you want to help them feel better and
so again it you read each individual and
you look at their own personality and
psychology and be and you learn that
through their behavior
and then you use that
and you try to make uh a bridge so that
they feel comfortable coming over to
your side rather than being bullied or
forced over yeah i almost feel like this
so so who i almost feel like this person
that can probably get the most out of uh
the case has to be as unemotional
emotionally disattached from the
situation as possible that you bring
from the outside they can sit down and
talk to them because if you're
emotionally attached to the situation
you're not going to be able to
handle the situation properly so it's
probably not the job of everybody either
i think it takes the right personality
to be able to do that yeah we call it a
clinical detachment just like a surgeon
focuses only on the area that they're
that they're doing surgery on but but
actually emotion could be an important
component of it it's just that you can't
carry the negative emotion into it what
you have to do is separate your own
feelings about whatever they did yeah
and look at it clinically but then you
also have to be willing to be very
emotional with someone sometimes it's
literally making a connection putting
your hand on their shoulder on the knee
telling them look at me i'm i'm serious
this is your opportunity to help
yourself this is your opportunity to
come clean this is your opportunity to
not be haunted by this for the rest of
your life whatever is the best approach
because you really want them to get
get to a point where they will tell you
the truth and that's your that's your
ultimate goal the last thing you want
somebody to do is tell you something
that isn't true because they want the
pain to stop that's right that's right
so to just kind of uh
you know and we see that happening it
happens in relationships it happens in
you know
kids with their parent relationship boss
employee relation happens everywhere but
let's go back to uh what i brought up
earlier when you said uh snipers have a
god complex so can you unpack that what
do you mean when you say snipers have a
god complex
whenever we at the behavioral analysis
unit look at a crime at a series of
crimes
we reverse engineer back to the type of
person who committed that crime so
basically
in the case of snipers the choice the
weapon choice is one of distance
the whole point is that there is no
physical connection between the offender
and the victim in a sniper case and the
sniper chooses to take life from above
and afar
and that's very godlike
whereas there are other offenders who
want to get up close and personal manual
strangulation
stabbing those things are are sort of in
your face and
that it requires a different type of
personality and generally people choose
to snipe versus
actually one-on-one contact with their
victims
because they feel
they want to feel omnipotent they want
to feel powerful and in this case so so
for example if
if you look at the dc sniper case
one of the major issues in that case was
that
there was a dichotomy between
how
this person
planned and executed shootings
flawlessly
and how
they communicated to us
through written
the written word and
jim fitzgerald who was sitting next to
me in the in the bau
said everybody was talking about in this
sniper case how this guy
six times
within 27 hours one shot one killed he
was in and out he there was no
decompensation there was no adrenaline
rush that made him make mistakes he was
a ghost
and everybody said he's got to be
older
settled
police or military trained and have
police or military experience because
it's not as easy to pull the trigger on
human beings as it is on paper targets
and so
everybody was agreeing to that but then
jim fitzgerald said yeah but if you look
at this tarot card
and this letter that they left us
it says this is for you mr police
and that told fitzgerald that that the
writer was looking up to the police
not like from a powerful position
omnipotent position but from below
and he
mr police is is a common phrase in
in reggae songs in the caribbean and so
he felt there was a caribbean influence
here and that the person was younger and
even one of the one of the
communications had those little stars
that you put on a kindergartener's paper
or picture
like what the hell what kind of a
sophisticated 45 year old is gonna put
that on a communication to the cops
so [ __ ] says
if he's an adult he's barely an adult
but he's more likely 15 or 16
and everybody just blew up at that and i
said
look then
either
this guy is incredibly poised and
sophisticated when he plans and executes
his shootings
but he decompensates when he's
communicating to us or for the first
time in u.s history we have a sniper
team
and the rest of the people said what are
you crazy snipers have a god complex
they don't work well together they've
never done it in the history of u.s
crime why would this happen now and i
said well you could do it if one of
them's 45
and one of them's 15
and this one is controlling that one the
younger one
and
if he's controlling him completely he
may be sexually victimizing him to do
that
and everybody said well you're an expert
in that field so that's why you know
you've got to hammer everything looks
like you nailed to you you're just
superimposing that well it turned out
about 10 or 11 years later malvo came
out and said
almost from day one that muhammad had
been sexually victimizing him
and so
those things those behaviors leaked out
information that they didn't intend to
give us so we put that into the profile
that they were african-american and one
was 45 and one was 15
and that they would probably have a
caribbean influence in their life and
and within 24 hours they were arrested
now we we go through that in in in in a
audible original series that we created
call me god where my brother and i tell
our different stories because we both
tim and i worked that case together we
were sort of off the grid because we
weren't supposed to be working the case
but these shootings happened in our own
neighborhood
and we couldn't let it go tim's wife was
at the same gas pump
that one of the victims was shot at 10
10 minutes later that's how close to
home it was so
these cases sometimes
you can't avoid working them you know
they you're drawn into them and tim and
i had a very different way of looking at
it he was out with he's a sniper
he knows snipers he was out hunting
with his swat team
looking for opportunities where they
might strike nets and he was one mile
away from the home depot
when an actual fbi employee was shot and
killed at that home depot he was the
first law enforcement officer to arrive
at that scene and we were very early on
the scene in the in the fredericksburg
shooting uh situations because that's
where we lived at the time so
the fact is that the behavior that these
offenders exhibited told us that for the
first time in us history
we had a sniper team they had a god
complex muhammad certainly had a god
complex and he was trying to ingrain
that into malvo
but malvo would never have been involved
in that level of violence had it not
been for muhammad
basically forcing him into it what a
technical case though i mean
how how does one make those two
connections with a 45 year old and a
teen because you're getting a feel of
both when they communicate doesn't
i mean that
it's funny because tim found the found
the letter at one of the shooting scenes
in ashland virginia and that letter gave
me and jim fitzgerald and the rest of my
team
the information i mean it leaked out
information that's what behavior does
that's
they call us in not when there's you
know plenty of dna and blood evidence
and the weapons found at the scene
our video of the offender exists they
calls in where there's nothing and we
take the behavior and as i said we
reverse engineer back to the type of
person who committed the crime there's
so many things so in that case victim
choice they were random victims again
that goes along with the god complex
it's not like he had a connection with
these victims he just wanted to take
life indiscriminately
and that again that gave us more and
more information about him every time he
pulled the trigger we learned more about
him and his behavior and every time he
communicated with us which we always try
to encourage
they act absolutely give much more
information than they think
fascinating the the there's a re there's
a community that doesn't like fbi agents
especially the last five years because
you guys got a black eye the last five
years but there is a need for what you
guys do the right agents are extremely
necessary because these are things that
regular people on a day-to-day basis to
put the connect the dots like that it's
a very tough thing to do that's why you
guys are professionals well we're we're
we're fortunate enough to have the
national center for the analysis of
violent crime to get to study crime
violent and sexual crime
24 hours a day 365. and because of that
we get to share that information with
law enforcement across the country and
around the world and that is a privilege
and an honor and i think if you look at
the history of the fbi yeah there have
been some
ups and downs and and the the the thing
about the fbi though is generally it
does not get involved in politics the
agents who work the investigations
uh they do their job irrespective of
what's going on in the country or who
what political party is there
maybe some of the upper echelon people
might be influenced by it but certainly
the people who are doing the
investigations and putting their lives
on the line
not an easy job doing it for the victims
not an easy job man not it's not an easy
job you guys got so let's talk deception
let's talk deception so okay you know
people are always fascinated by telling
whether somebody's lying or not like i
think there's even channels on youtube
where all they do is they sit there
and they say look when he did this he's
lying look when he went like this he's
lying look out he's trying to deceive
you by making
doing everything you're supposed to do
to act like he's nervous but he's acting
he's not really like that it's not
really him there's there's there's a
business for that there's books that are
written about this because absolutely
people want to know this so
obviously you've said it there is
nothing that's disputable like there's
no you know but for the most
indisputable disputable unique thing
that can tell you somebody is lying you
have to norm that person it's all
individuals you have to norm that person
wow
it's
people
have their own idiosyncrasies yeah and
some people are very nervous in general
and they get totally calm when they're
lying
some people are looking all over the
place and they'll
look right in your eyes
when they're lying
there's there's a whole bunch of
different theories that we use we blend
them together in the fbi we don't use
one theory but there's fight or flight
because when people get really nervous
they'll get fidgety because their body
is pumping blood and pumping adrenaline
to their extremities so sometimes
they'll fidget or their their hands will
go all over the place they'll they'll
fix their hair they'll adjust themselves
whatever it is
but that is only one aspect that you
look at you have to spend time i told
you earlier when we're doing
interrogations we tell people
the minimum you should spend
is four hours
because the chances of you getting an
accurate and reliable confession
increase 25
with each hour that you spend and those
four hours should be spent learning
about that person
getting as much information about them
and their behavior as possible because
then
when you put the hard questions to them
then you
after having taken in all this
information about the person then you
will be able to notice the changes in
their behavior and those changes are the
reg flags those are the areas that you
want to dive into further but again a
lot of people say
micro expressions are absolutely a tell
well in some cases they are in some
cases they are not
the more intelligent a person is
the more
micro expressions they'll have
the lesser intelligent people
sometimes will will have no facial
indications at all that they're lying
they they their
facial expressions don't give away much
at all
but their behaviors or the words or
their language or how they use certain
words or the changes in words
it's a very complicated thing i used to
teach deception detection at the fbi
academy uh believe me it's it's a months
long course it's not something i can
just summarize in one day but i will
tell you this in the fbi
we
actually
believe
that if people
if people
are lying to you
that there are going to be indications
that they are lying
but you have to understand that
individual person before you can ever
hope to know if any person is actually
lying
i love the four-hour rule every hour 25
goes up you need four to get to the norm
the more intelligent the more signs
they'll give you the less intelligent
the less signs they'll give you
uh
just out of curiosity and they may do
impression management the intelligent
people will give you what they think you
expect from a truthful person and that
might be looking right into your eyes
when at the very point when they're
lying and that you have to see that
that's a change in their behavior why
did he stare in my eyes that time but
all this other time he's telling me
about his favorite team where he goes to
work how he drives to work you know what
he drinks at night
all these things and he's just looking
all over the place but when he said he
wasn't there on the fourth
he was looking straight in my eyes
now most people believe that gay's
aversion looking away is an indicator of
lying when in that case it could be
looking at you is the indicator so if
you didn't norm that person you would
never know it and you would think he's
lying about the wrong things but another
really important thing
to prevent false confessions
is to make sure that you never just take
it at face value you see indications of
lying and you you dive in
but the person could be lying
about something totally different in
other words
they they don't want to give you the
actual alibi because they were having an
affair with someone and they can't say i
was at this motel with so and so
because
even in a homicide investigation the
last thing they want is their wife's
anger they don't want to be called out
on the affair so they're they're lying
about something but it's not
the homicide that you're investigating
so you have to be incredibly careful
once you get indicators of deception
yeah those are the areas you have to
dive deeper into and get more details
out
that's insane to go
look how important you think it is uh uh
the president americans choose every
four to eight years
how important do i do the point of the
decision is that for us
i think it's a ping-pong match i think
it's a pendulum swing i think in the
united states of america we haven't yet
figured out that middle of the road is
the best way to go rather than extreme
here or extreme there i would much
rather see some coalition or something
down the middle that didn't cause you
know extreme changes these four or eight
years and then that's undone for the
next four to eight years uh it wastes
money it wastes time and it wastes
people's livelihoods and people's lives
and it weakens it weakens the the
foundation of what this country was
founded on you know it does and i i do
believe that
if if people i mean there are some
countries that have have tripartite
coalitions so that everybody's
represented i don't think that's a bad
idea but you know it hasn't come here
yet but let's let's face it
politics comes and goes the things i'm
talking about the things that we're
discussing here these things have been
developed over the last 100 plus here's
where i was going with this question
where i was going with this question was
you know one time i did a uh a show
you know guys call me they want to do
debate so one time i had
uh alan dershowitz which i don't know if
you know who he is the uh okay so i had
him
debate robert kennedy robert's good
friend so i had them too
alan was saying if the government wants
to mandate they can even though he
disagrees they can't mandate and uh rfq
is saying there's no way in the world
they can mandate these are both
attorneys one is the best environmental
attorney the other one is you know you
know who allen is so then i had another
guy that came and debated uh
one was the director developmental from
normal which they want to legalize
marijuana everywhere and the other one
was a christian
navy
commander and they came and they debated
marijuana and on the bottom every time
somebody told a lie we would just go
or if it was green check with the facts
below it right
what do you think we can do do you think
presidential election 2023 we should
have these guys lined up with live
detective tests and every time they say
something you see a score behind him at
the audience it's like he's lying she's
lying how do you think we can improve
the debates well unfortunately the
polygraph is actually a tool not a
be-all and end-all sure
itself doesn't actually tell if
somebody's lying i mean there has to be
a human being that interacts with it
there are a number of things there are
people that have these stress analyzers
and voice stress analyzers and things
like that that they think they can tell
um again
you you like the truth serum
yeah no
but there no but there are people so i'm
calling the polygraph
because
they're extremely honest
and they're very they have this sort of
ingrained in them this fear of of doing
something wrong and so they're very
fidgety and and nervous and they sweat a
lot and it and it gives the appearance
on a polygraph of lying there are other
people who when they're being asked the
questions will because this is the thing
our conscious mind operates at about
in thousands of a second we can make
decisions and movements in thousands of
a second but our subconscious mind
operates in trillionths of a second 10
billion times faster wow and so while
we're being asked conscious questions
subconsciously we're saying wow i'm glad
i didn't do that when i was a kid
and and that is what comes out in your
body actions and so
your your brain can think about things
so much faster than your mouth can
answer questions and so that's something
that the polygraph doesn't do yet now
they'll eventually come up with brain
scans that are that are that are showing
really incredible detail and i know they
have some of that going on now i think
technology will eventually get a lot
better at lie detecting but
you have to always understand human
beings
make decisions in the privacy of their
brain
and those decisions can affect how they
outwardly
express truth and lies and when you
know somebody best you i'm sure you have
children when one of your kids a
teenager comes home late and they say
you say where were you
it will take you a fraction of a second
maybe a thousandth of a second to tell
whether they're telling the truth or a
lie why because you made that person you
know that person intimately you know
everything about how they re respond to
you if law enforcement officers can get
get that level of detail when they're
interrogating somebody they'll never
have a problem telling whether
somebody's telling the truth or a lie
unfortunately they have to do it in a
much more compressed way so preparation
for any interviewer interrogation is
what's critical
knowing that person knowing as much
about them as possible and drawing out
as much more in the time you spend with
them those are the keys to actually
getting truthful confessions so here's
what i want to do since we have you on i
i want the audience to see
your ability your gift what you see that
we don't see i want us to profile
somebody okay okay and i was trying to
have the guys pull up which one we were
gonna do
i can't use a clip from another channel
it has to be like a c-span type of a
thing where you know it's it's uh what
do you call it it's not uh cnn or msnbc
or fox because we can commentate on it i
found a recent one from two weeks ago
and i'm curious to know what you say
about this one here
and and i'll play it whatever comments
you got on it you tell us now in this
exchange to preface before the audience
sees it
you know uh
fouchy gain of function rand paul is
calling them out with nih all this stuff
the only feedback i want to get from you
is when they're going back whatever
feedback you give us is great but
fauci's reaction and rand paul's
reaction
and it will just listen to you so i'm
going to press play okay we'll see
hopefully i can get i don't expect you
today to admit that you approved of nih
funding for gain and function research
in wuhan
but your repeated denials have worn thin
and a majority of americans frankly
don't believe you
even the nih now admits that eco health
alliance did perform experiments in
wuhan that created viruses not found in
nature that actually did gain in
lethality
the facts are clear the nih did fund
gain of function research in wuhan
despite your protestations you can deny
it all you want but even the chinese
authors of the paper in their paper
admit
that
viruses not found in nature were created
and yes they gained an infectivity
your persistent denials though are not
simply a stain on your reputation
but are clear and present danger to the
country and to the world
as professor kevin s felt of mit has
written gain of function research looks
like a gamble that civilization can't
afford to risk
and yet here we are again with you
steadfast in your denials
why does it matter
because gain of function research with
laboratory created viruses not found in
nature could cause a pandemic even worse
the next time
we're suffering today from one that has
a mortality of approximately one percent
they're experimenting with viruses that
have mortalities of between 15 and 50
percent
yes our civilization could be at risk
from one of these viruses
experiments that combine unknown viruses
with known pandemic causing viruses are
incredibly risky experiments that
combine unknown viruses with
coronaviruses that have as much as 50
mortality could endanger civilization as
we know it and here you sit
unwilling to accept any responsibility
for the current pandemic and unwilling
to take any steps to prevent gain of
function research from possibly
unleashing an even more deadly virus
you mislead the public by saying that
the published viruses could not be
coveted well exactly no one is alleging
that no one is alleging that the
published viruses by the chinese are
coveted what we are saying is that this
was risky
type of research gain of function
research it was risky to share this with
the
with the chinese and that covid may have
been created from a not yet revealed
virus we don't anticipate the chinese
are going to reveal the virus if it came
from their lab
you know that but you continue to
mislead you continue to support nih
money going to wuhan you continue to say
you trust the chinese scientist
you appear to have learned nothing from
this pandemic
will you today finally take some
responsibility for funding gain of
function research in wuhan
senator with all due respect i disagree
with so many of the things that you've
said
again first of all gain of function
is a very nebulous term we have spent
not us but outside bodies a considerable
amount of effort to give a more precise
definition to the type
of research that is of concern
that might lead to a dangerous situation
you are aware of that that is called p3
co we're aware that you deleted gain of
function from the nih website well i can
get back to that a moment if we have
time
but let's get back to the operating
framework and guidewells of which we
operate under
and you have ignored them
the guidelines are very very clear that
you have to be dealing with a pathogen
that clearly is shown and very likely to
be highly transmissible in an
uncontrollable way
in humans and to have a high degree you
have an apology so how does it feel so
far he is very poised and calm and very
focused and
what senator rand was doing was putting
lots
of words in his mouth in other words he
was he was quoting dr fauci over and
over again he was telling dr fauci what
dr fauci has done
that you know that he's he's he's
basically giving him all these kinds of
negative things
the of course we're only seeing we don't
have a constant camera on him which
would have been nice but we're seeing
cutbacks to dr fauci and and he's
basically
placid yeah even the breathing when he
answered at first i don't know if you
caught that his breathing was a little
bit let me go back to it i wonder what
that means because these guys are
getting ready yeah he he's definitely
getting ready to to
say something i believe he's you're what
you're seeing is controlled behavior in
other words he probably wants to say
dude you're lying to me you are lying to
the public you know a lot more than what
you're saying but
fauci has to be composed he has to be
professional if he if he gets in
senator's face he's going to look
disrespectful and it's going to be used
against him so i think what he was
trying to do was
okay i'm just going to try to give this
in a measured
professional way and not respond
negatively to all the very bad things
that you've just claimed about me so
nothing so far seems suspicious from
fauci's side to you
nothing nothing that they've shown me
but again i haven't been seeing him the
whole time but let me go back to uh let
me go back to here like what is this
when he answers and he's like take a
look at this one here senator with all
due respect i disagree with so many of
the things that you've said
first of all gain a function okay so
pause it there senator all due respect i
just dealing with somebody who he had to
take notes he wrote down some notes so
he could remember to make a particular
point because as he opens there's so
many things that you just said that i
disagree with so i think he wanted to
make sure that he hit these particular
points so he moved the paper in front of
him there's nothing about
i i look at the totality of everything
not just how his hands move how his eyes
move how his facial expressions change
because there isn't much in terms of
facial expression change in here and
again
that's someone who is intelligent that's
someone who controls himself he
he he almost took a little
you know sort of like a deep breath
before you're about to sort of let loose
but
you want to hold back so let's continue
let's see
let's see here next because
i'm going to go to
this part hence that hence the word
e-p-p-p
enhanced pathogens of potentia
so when echo health alliance took the
virus
and combined it with wiv-1 and caused a
recombinant virus that doesn't exist in
nature and it made my sicker mice that
had humanized cells you're saying that
that's not gain of function research
according to the framework and
guidelines so what you're doing is
defining a weigh gain a function you're
simply saying it doesn't exist because
you changed the definition on the nih
website this is terrible and you're
you're completely trying to escape the
idea that we should do something about
trying to prevent a pandemic from
leaking from a lab there's the
preponderance of evidence now points
towards this coming from the lab and
what you've done is change the
definition on your website to try to
cover your ass basically that's what
you've done you've changed the website
to try to have a new definition that
doesn't include the risky research
that's going on until you admit that
it's risky we're not going to get
anywhere you have to admit that this
research was risky the nih has now
rebuked them your own agency has rebuked
them
but that thing is is you're still
unwilling to admit that they gained in
function when they say they became
sicker they gained in lethality it's a
new virus that's not gain of function
according to the definition that is
currently operable
you know senator
let's make it clear for the people who
are listening
the current definition
was done over a two to three year period
by outside bodies including the nsabb
two conferences by the national academy
of science engineering and medicine
on december 2014
march
2016.
we commissioned external risk benefit
assessment
and then on january of 2017
the office of science and technology
policy of the white house
issued the current policy and
coincidence i have not seen the
definition
on the same day the nih said that yes
there was a gain of function in wuhan
the same day the definition appeared the
new definition to try to define a way
what's going on in wuhan until you
accept it until you expect accept
responsibility we're not going to get
anywhere close to trying to prevent
another live leak of this dangerous sort
of experiment you won't admit that it's
dangerous and for that lack of judgment
i think it's time that you resign thank
you senator paul and i would like um to
give the time to dr patrick yeah well
there were so many things pause right
here just how far is representation here
i mean this is a this is a man who's
very frustrated by the circumstances dr
fauci is not able to get the words out
that he hoped to say and he feels
he you can see now his level of
frustration has has
removed some of his composure and he's
trying now to actually get out
the foundational statements that he
believes will support his position
rather than the senators it's a it's a
very difficult situation i know for a
fact that in situations like this there
are many
hearings that go on
outside the uh the purview of the
cameras that that people have done
interviews beforehand and a lot of of
what is said
is it's it's a show it's like a trial
there's admissible stuff and there's
inadmissible stuff and
unfortunately
it's not an equally weighted situation a
senator in in sitting on the on the in
the tall chairs uh has more power than
than any witness that's going to be
sitting in front of them so i can see
the stress coming out and dr fauci here
and again
i
i would be
irresponsible to say that i know that
that stress is because he's lying uh the
stress can be come come from many
different angles
i would like to spend more time with
bauchi and get to know him and get to
know what he's like under stress as well
as
whether or not he
he
is capable of
of
of of lying
and
being completely impervious to
indicators of that because it's a
possibility especially when somebody is
is intelligent
clearly he is intelligent but you don't
see what what you would
generally see in
in a
in a person who
who's just panicking because they've
been caught in a lot quote caught in a
lot did he look like he was panicking a
little bit he looked like he was
panicking a little bit to me i don't
know yeah well what i said was at the
end he was definitely he definitely
looked like he was stressed but
from what i've seen and again this is
just my uh observation from what i've
seen
he was cut off in the middle of his
explanation he was he he resorted to
reading the definition from a piece of
paper because he did not want to
um
get interrupted and not give that
information out it's a like i said it's
just it's a very difficult situation to
be in but
could he have uh funded
the this
what was it called
something gain a function gain of
function is
could he have fun could he have
uh knowingly funded gain and function
research and uh like the senator said
they changed the definition in the
process uh it's it's possible i mean
it's i wouldn't rule it out
but again i i don't feel like i have
enough information to tell you that that
is what he's
getting stressed about i can tell you
he's getting stressed but i can also
come up with two different possibilities
of why he's stressed yeah you know the
situation or because he's lying you know
the the the challenge is you know uh at
first when they introduced this guy i
mean nobody knew him except for the
people that studied it you know they
knew he was part of the aids pandemic
back in the 80s and you know uh where he
has been around he's been doing this for
a while then all of a sudden it's like
the trust in a guy keeps going lower
then one day jon stewart comes out
on uh stephen colbert's show and he says
look why can't we go investigate the
fact that this was man-made or not in
china why is that such a no-no why can't
we talk about it
and that caused a big frenzy in the
media where everybody started talking
and saying maybe we ought to find that
because the world stopped let's face a
lot of kids didn't go to school they
were homeschooling we don't know the
residual effects of this 5 10 15 20
years from now but everybody was somehow
directly or indirectly affected by it
i'm just curious when you see these
things
um
and see signs of it because he looked
very very
nervous to me like you know when you
show that one clip of nixon
and nixon says you know i'm not a crook
like if there's anybody who's not
supposed to say there's a president he
says i have so much confidence that if
you want to investigate this you know
that whole thing you were uh
highlighting and and then the way
clinton put it
which i have had no sexual relationship
there is there is no sexual relationship
it is right now
i am yeah i am not having sex without
right now
right yeah so you know these guys are
such professionals with wordsmithing so
you don't necessarily know but the
reality is you know if
anthony fauci gets recognized by
guardian as the sexiest man of life
maybe we ought to hold him accountable
for what decisions he's made on what we
need to do with this because i don't
know if you're laughing or not he was
really recognized as the sexiest man
alive my god
i'm actually being dead serious
you you you didn't know about this he
was well no i didn't i didn't know about
how you know
you just heard from the sexiest man
alive that's what you just gives me hope
i mean you know
i we should we should go tweet guardian
and say hey can we make the top 10 list
i don't know
put a list for it but okay uh uh final
thoughts here i know you uh uh run a uh
podcast as well called best case worst
case and you guys sit there and actually
bring people in and you go through
different cases tell us a little about
the podcast you guys run so yeah francie
hanks and i francie was a former state
and federal prosecutor and she and i
interviewed cops and
lawyers and related law enforcement
professionals about the best case and
the worst case of their career the point
is we want to show people in the public
what the spectrum and the continuum of
cases is like for a law enforcement
officer street cops detectives
prosecutors defense attorneys everybody
in that process
we haven't yet interviewed a judge we'd
love to but everybody in that process is
affected by the cases that come before
them and there are people who have
literally spent two three four decades
working on a case to ultimately resolve
it because they couldn't let it go and
some of these cases really affect people
i know that they have affected me
even though i developed a clinical
detachment while i'm working on the case
while i'm analyzing a case of of you
know brutality or or
sexual victimization i have to detach
clinically while i'm doing it but i'm
still a human being and i understand
what when that person went through and i
have a tremendous amount of empathy and
and many law enforcement officers carry
around all this
pain and suffering that they are exposed
to
and it can ruin lives and marriages you
know on the part of law enforcement
officers and especially when the public
is
is sort of geared up against them and
and they still are out there risking
their lives
every day to try to keep the peace
and this is the goal of best case worst
case to show how
who these people are that choose a life
of law enforcement and how their careers
can go from
one extreme of of
success to
another extreme of of just horrific
failure
well we're going to put the link below
below to your podcast i love the name
best case uh worst case like i said
earlier uh from watching your videos
being a great teacher man listening to
you
i get smarter about your world of how
you do what you do all aspects of it i
appreciate you for taking the time and
being a guest on valuetainment by the
way
some tells me if you and your uh co-host
were to take a little bit more time to
go deeper and study more of the fouchy
rand paul back and forth they've had
like six rounds if this was a rocky
they're on rocky 12 already i mean
they've gone back and forth so there's
so much content for you to come up to
your four-hour number to increase the 25
rate i think if you did that i think you
may get a few million downloads of that
episode because the world is very
curious so all right well i will i will
definitely tell francie about your
suggestion and and we'll do that because
one of the things is that francie and i
we have this sort of brother-sister kind
of situation where we kind of you know
sort of uh you know
gig each other and poke poke at each
other and and we have very different
ways of looking at things so it would be
great it would be great
if you guys do that and it's a long form
i would share it
with everybody a matter of fact we may
even bring both of you guys in for a
live podcast and share it with everybody
and drive even more people to your
podcast so but i'd be curious be very
curious i'm writing it down right now
jim the moment you guys get to text us
let us know we'll we'll uh we'll follow
up with you guys on that but jim once
again appreciate your time sincerely i
really enjoyed it thank you thank you so
much for having me and taking time thank
you so do you feel like you're qualified
now to be an fbi agent maybe at least go
apply for what an interesting way of how
they detect everything and what they do
right i was fascinated by it if you
enjoyed it as much as i had to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
two other interviews for you heard me
talk a lot about paul malerie from uk if
you've never seen in mallory click over
here to watch the interview the other
one is an interview i did with former
insider fbi agent donny barrasco aka joe
pistone it's got like 5 million views if
you've never seen that absolutely
fascinating click here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]